EARLIER TODAY, GOLF PRO JOHN
DALY, A SPORTSCASTER JIM WILL
JOIN US.
FIRST, DISTURBING NEWS STARTING
JOE BIDEN.
AFTER INEXPLICABLY CANCELING
PUBLIC EVENTS THE LAST FEW
WEEKS, JOE IS NOW STRUGGLING TO,
WELL, EVEN FORM SENTENCES AND
SPEAK, AT TIMES, IN WHAT IS A
COHERENT WAY.
EARLIER, HE ATTEMPTED TO USE A
CHEAT SHEET TO DELIVER SOME
EXTEMPORANEOUS REMARKS.
IT DIDN’T EXACTLY GO WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I PROMISE YOU, WE ARE GOING
TO TOGETHER BEAT THIS, AND I
THINK THAT -- I, YOU KNOW -- BUT
THE IDEA, OVER 500 -- I THINK IT
IS -- I CARRY A CARD WITH ME
EVERY DAY.
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE...
AS OF YESTERDAY, THERE ARE
500,071 PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED
FROM THIS.
>> Sean: OH, AND THE MEDIA
LIKES TO ATTACK ME FOR SAYING
"YEAH, HE LOOKS WEAK, FRAIL, AND
SEEMS TO BE STRUGGLING
COGNITIVELY."
WHAT IS ON THE NOTE CARD, JOE?
YOUR NAME, YOUR ADDRESS, CONTACT
INFORMATION, NAME OF YOUR WIFE,
WHAT YOUR ADDRESS IS,
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, IF YOU
GET LOST, A REMINDER NOT TO
MENTION THE CORRUPT FAMILY
BUSINESS.
IN ALL HONESTY, THIS IS NOW
GETTING SCARY.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE OUR
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
AND THIS IS PROBABLY THE
TOUGHEST, AND SINGLE MOST
DEMANDING JOB IN THE WORLD.
THAT IS WHY YOU CAN’T HAVE A
MEDIA MOB, BIG TECH, CANDIDATE
PROTECTION PROGRAM, AND RUN A
CAMPAIGN HIDING IN YOUR BASEMENT
BUNKER.
AND JOE SEEMINGLY CAN BARELY
FORM A SENTENCE IN BETWEEN NAPS.
AND MEANWHILE, THERE IS A
SERIOUS DEVELOPING SITUATION
RIGHT AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AFTER BIDEN VOWED TO ALLOW MORE
REFUGEES INTO THE U.S. AND
HALTED ALL BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION, ILLEGAL CROSSINGS
ARE NOW WAY UP.
NOT A SURPRISE.
THIS INCLUDES KIDS UNDER THE AGE
OF 18.
THAT IS FORCING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO OPEN AN
EMERGENCY FACILITY FOR KIDS, OR
IS THE MEDIA MOB USED TO CALL
IT, UNDER DONALD TRUMP, KIDS IN
CAGES.
THIS TIME, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
TINY TRAILERS THAT LOOK LIKE
SHIPPING CONTAINERS WITH BARS ON
THE WINDOWS, BUT
"WASHINGTON POST," MEDIUM
OUTLIVE ALL THINGS RADICAL
SOCIALIST, THEY ARE POLITELY
REFERRING TO THIS AS A
MIGRANT FACILITY FOR CHILDREN.
OH, WITH BARS ON THE WINDOWS.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE HYPOCRISY
COMING UP.
BUT FIRST, LET’S TAKE A STEP
BACK AND LET’S REVIEW HOW WE GOT
THERE.
WE START, THE YEARS 2014, AND
THAT IS WHEN THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA ENCOUNTERED A
MASSIVE WAVE OF MIGRANT CARAVANS
FILLED WITH UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
IN ORDER TO PROCESS AND HOW IS
THESE MIGRANTS, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ACQUIRED A
WAREHOUSE, AND THEY USED, YOU
GOT IT, A CHAIN-LINK FENCE TO
DIVIDE CHILDREN FROM ADULTS.
IN THE FOLLOWING YEARS, THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THEY
CONTINUED TO USE THE OBAMA
FACILITY FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND OTHER MIGRANT
CHILDREN WHOSE PARENTS WERE
BEING PROSECUTED FOR CRIMES AND
DID THE SAME THING OBAMA DID.
THIS WAS A TEMPORARY HOLDING
FACILITY WHERE CHILDREN WERE HOW
IS FOR LESS THAN A WEEK.
BUT IN 2018, THE MOB, THE MEDIA,
THEY BECAME HYSTERICAL AFTER
THEY UNEARTHED PHOTOS
CIRCULATING, SHOWING KIDS BEHIND
A CHAIN-LINK FENCE.
WELL, AS IT TURNED OUT, MANY OF
THOSE PHOTOS ARE ACTUALLY FROM
THE OBAMA ERA.
BUT THE TRUTH, IT DOESN’T SEEM
TO MATTER TO THE MEDIA MOB, TO
DEMOCRATS, TO BIG TECH
COMPANIES.
THEY ONLY SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
SMEARING, SLANDERING,
BESMIRCHING, ATTACKING
DONALD TRUMP EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
SO, THEY ACCUSED HIM OF PUTTING
KIDS IN CAGES.
"WASHINGTON POST" WROTE THAT THE
CHAIN-LINK FENCE WAS A SYMBOL OF
MISTREATMENT.
KAMALA HARRIS HERSELF CALLED IT
IMMORAL AND WRONG AND
UNNECESSARY.
JOE BIDEN SAID IT WAS ONE OF THE
DARKEST MOMENTS IN OUR HISTORY.
WELL, HE DID IT.
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ VISITED
ONE OF THE FACILITIES AT THE
BORDER AND DRAMATICALLY WEPT IN
FRONT OF A PHOTOGRAPHER WHILE
CLINGING TO A CHAIN-LINK FENCE.
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND DID CHILD
SEPARATION POLICY, ULTIMATELY
CLOSED THE SOUTH TEXAS FACILITY
FOR RENOVATIONS.
NOW, THANKS TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, A BRAND-NEW
BEAUTIFUL HOLDING FACILITY FOR
KIDS WITH BARS ON THE WINDOWS IS
BACK.
IT’S OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
NOW, THESE TINY THINGS THAT LOOK
LIKE SHIPPING CONTAINERS, ARE
NOW HOUSING UNDERAGE MIGRANTS.
WE JUST CAN’T SEE THEM.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
PRAISING THE FACILITIES AND
HIGHLIGHTING ALL THE WONDERFUL
AMENITIES, INCLUDING "COLORFUL
TRAILER AT THE ENTRYWAY, WHERE
FLOWERS AND BUTTERFLIES AND
HANDMADE POSTERS HANGING ON ITS
WALLS."
TONIGHT, TO HER CREDIT,
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ, AT
LEAST SHE IS A DEMOCRAT THAT IS
BEING CONSISTENT, AND SHE IS
BLASTING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI WANTS
YOU TO KNOW THAT THESE ARE
DEFINITELY NOT CAGES LIKE THE
LAST TIME.
THEY ARE DELIGHTFUL TRAILERS
THAT LOOK LIKE SHIPPING
CONTAINERS WITH BARS ON THE
WINDOWS AND BUTTERFLIES AND
SUNSHINE AND COTTON CANDY ON THE
WALLS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT’S THE SAME FACILITY THAT
WAS OPEN IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
UNDER TERM, THERE HAVE BEEN
HORRIFYING THINGS AT THE BORDER
AND KIDS IN CAGES.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID THE CAGES ARE
A HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSE COMMITTED
BY THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT?
>> Secretary Psaki: WE FEEL
THAT WAY.
THIS IS NOT KIDS BEING KEPT IN
CAGES.
THIS IS A FACILITY THAT WAS OPEN
THAT IS GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
STANDARDS AS OTHER HHS
FACILITIES.
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT -- I WAS
NEVER OUR INTENTION OF
REPLICATING THE POLICIES OF THE
PAST ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: LET ME MAKE A
PREDICTION.
JEN PSAKI, SHE IS GOING TO
CIRCLE BACK ON THIS ONE SINCE
THE SITUATION AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS ONLY GOING TO GET
DRAMATICALLY WORSE.
THAT, YOU CAN TAKE TO THE BANK.
BIDEN’S OPEN BORDER POLICIES ARE
A GREEN LIGHT FOR MIGRANTS, AND
IN THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS,
MARK MY WORDS, THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER HUGE, MASSIVE UPTICK IN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
NOW THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
GIVEN THAT BIDEN’S PICK FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL, MERRICK
GARLAND, ISN’T EVEN SURE THAT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS ILLEGAL.
HE WANTS TO BE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, HE’S NOT
SURE IS A LEGAL.
OKAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE ILLEGAL ENTRY
AT AMERICA’S BORDERS SHOULD
REMAIN A CRIME?
>> WELL, I HAVEN’T THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT QUESTION, I JUST HAVEN’T
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT QUESTION.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT
HAS MADE CLEAR THAT WE ARE A
COUNTRY WITH BORDERS AND WITH A
CONCERN ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY.
I DON’T KNOW OF A PROPOSAL TO
DECRIMINALIZE BUT STILL MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL TO ENTER.
I JUST DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION.
I HAVEN’T THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: LET ME GUESS, HE WILL
CIRCLE BACK, ALSO.
BY THE WAY, WHEN I WENT TO MEN
ONE OF MY MANY TRIPS TO THE
BORDER, 14 OR 15 OF THEM, I
STEPPED OVER THE SIDE, AND WAS
ACCUSED OF ILLEGAL ENTRY INTO
THE COUNTRY, ONE STEP OVER.
CAN YOU BELIEVE OBAMA, THE
MEDIA, TRY TO SELL THAT GUY IS
THE NEXT MODERATE SUPREME COURT
U.S. JUSTICE?
HE IS GOING TO CIRCLE BACK.